chers amis chers ennemis bonsoir c'est
l'heure de faire des rg le seul jt de la
culture au sommaire ce soir art lyrique
à la une avec les représentations
exceptionnelles de samassa maroc chaque
chèque le nouveau opéra cirque du
catalan carlos santos fille notre
portrait de l'écrivain israélien amos oz
à l'occasion de la traduction chez
gallimard de seule la mère son nouveau
roman et enfin notre coup de zoom sur le
boom de la culture gothique sans oublier
nos deux invités du jour le comédien
andré dussollier à la fiche de monstres
sacrés sacré monstre au théâtre de la
gaîté montparnasse et demi ce bombardier
hauteur de ouf chez albin michel puis
hector obalk que les critiques qu'il
amuse pas la galerie enfin l'instant
critique aujourd'hui consacré au cinéma
avec notre cinéphilique trio elisabeth
quin michel boujut alain riou bonsoir à
tous
il y aura aussi pour soir à tous
d'ailleurs si je m'en sors a conçu
les plaisirs de lesbien le sama ruch suc
su que c'est quoi ouais samarut que
samassa ma rue c'est que c'est ça que tu
suces va venir en france et là dans le
dur
moi je vais trio lisez des
triolets l'environnement kahn parce
qu'alors là c'est là où c'est les fonds
de tiroir dites-moi est-ce que tous ces
films ont marché le raid le boulet 3-0
dites moi un petit peu 3-0 pas mal ouais
pas autant que mais forcément il ya eu
un 21 avril qui est passé dessus leur
aide je ne sais pas le boulet non plus
par contre énorme boum sur la bande
originale du début du film d'almodovar
avec la chanson que tout le monde se
passent en boucle au long cours ou
coucou revoilà alors
caetano veloso retrouve une deuxième
jeunesse en ce moment tout le monde je
ne réussis pas vous je sais pas moi je
suis
la chanson de caetano veloso et de huy
mahoney non mais la bande originale
aurait noué au moins cinq matches un peu
moi langoureuse un peu moins comme ça
merveilleux sa
superbe
vous parlez du soulier nom du chevalier
parle
d'accord voilà très bien voilà
rien sur les sites aujourd'hui un jérôme
lecou pour me censure
intervenir comme je voudrais
je voulais consacrer 1 éreintement à
thierry bizot puisque c'est un homme de
télé qui publie un roman un peu comme
xavier couture alors je me disais tiens
je vais encore me faire un ennemi
puissant dans l'audiovisuel et en fait
c'est un roman très drôle très réussi
sur une entreprise multinationale à
grouiller agroalimentaire qui s'appelle
bea france me dit ressemblent beaucoup à
madone et
je trouve
je trouve plutôt alors du coup je suis
emmerdé donc je fais pas un éreintement
du mercredi et c'est pour ça qu'on est
jeudi en fait oui c'est un grand
avantage c'est qu'on a dites moi donc
c'est un petit peu dans la lignée
beigbeder sa maintenance et les romances
aux entreprises plutôt rené victor
pilhes renouvelle ancien agriculteur
beaucoup c'est à dire c'est le regard de
quelqu'un qui a travaillé dans une
entreprise puisque thierry bizot était
chez l'oréal pendant huit ans et eux et
c'est utile de regarder parce que la
plupart des écrivains français n'ont
jamais mis les pieds dans un bureau
savent pas à quoi ça ressemble donc
c'est pas mal quelquefois que les gens
qui savent de quoi ils parlent ben le
raconte très bien j'ai fini du coup
maintenant je peux y aller
et vous bat andré dussollier vous l'avez
dit puis à notre cousine du québec
désiste bar gay away qui publie son
premier roman parce que le reste c'était
plutôt des essais enfin une habitude et
où les français lettre ouverte aux
français qui se croit le nombril du
monde elle avait fait qu'il souffrait
beaucoup à frédéric beigbeder a marre
avons un accord entre autres aux autres
entre autres c'est bien
et puis à qui a qui sont pas des bons
tous les gens qui critiquent et
québécois mardi son et voici leur accent
sur tf1 va voir peut-être qu'elle a
perdu un petit peu on commence dans les
représentations exceptionnelles de sama
sa maroc chaque sac
le nouvel opéra comique des catalans
carlos santos et l'espace chapiteaux du
parc de la villette jusqu'au 19 mai un
spectacle aussi iconoclaste
qu'acrobatiques dans lequel santos
bouscule les lois classiques de l'art
lyrique karine roy n'a pas déchanté
magnéto
invention dérision humour avec le
compositeur catalan carlos santos la
musique contemporaine et l'opéra en voit
de toutes les couleurs de formation
classique depuis 25 ans il met en scène
des spectacles lyriques aux partitions
et à la scénographie extravagantes
de fait les choses comme ça de 9,2
contre 9,1 jour de détruire un piano un
autre jour jouer avec les pieds
toujours aller à la mer avec un piano de
recherche comme ça
comme exercice des deux rapports avec
l'instrument avec la victime
on essaye de faire très chaud ce bijou
elle avec la musique le jazz et la
musique alors il ya un accord qui
intervient il ya le mouvement qui
intervient
toujours aussi curieux aujourd'hui à la
villette il invente une nouvelle forme
d'expression l'opéra cirque
les artistes de sylt
deviennent des personnages ils parlent
ils ont des rapports avec les autres
fonctions numéro mais en fonction de
quelque chose la difficulté
de la parole
amélie
en elle-même et de notre auteur et
chanteur réopéré dans la mire de
situation de dernière
minute et l'imaginaire de carrelet
santos n'a aucune limite devant un
rideau représentant un sexe féminin et
oui les chanteurs acrobates se plie à
toutes les excentricités
[Musique]
oh
j'ai jasé les côtés aux pédales elle
avec la musique pour l'on peut changer
un peu le rythme normal des services
accomplis dans toujours c'est le numéro
les gens ont applaudi
mois déjanté qu'à l'accoutumée et très
chaotique son dernier spectacle vaut
surtout le détour pour son
anticonformisme jubilatoire
il faut que les gens qui aiment l'opéra
vient voir les gens qui aiment la bougie
et les gens dociles qui vient aussi se
révéler comme on la mélange est ici
c'est parce que le public aussi voir ce
mélange est
là je repars le nord
il ya des otages canal
[Musique]
oh
ça
[Musique]
merci karine roy frédéric et bien oui
alors thierry bizot qui est il eh bien
ce n'est pas jean françois bizot c'est
un autre ce sont cousins ah oui dans son
cousin de sang coule annoncé son cousin
morceaux et alors vous voyez thierry
ardisson le connais pourquoi le
connaît-il parce que thierry bizot
travail à la télé et les producteurs
avec emmanuel chain d'une émission qui
s'appelle de 7 à 8 entre eux plus entre
autres et il a une société qui s'appelle
éléphant et compagnie tout là ses
ambitions et compagnie voyez vous donc
c'est sans doute cohérent et thierry
bizot dont la photo est qu'ici ça c'est
mon article ça c'est voit les photos de
mise au travail et thierry bizot a
travaillé huit ans chez l'oréal avant
d'entrer à m6 où il a été directeur des
magazines et de la musique et puis il a
créé sa boîte de prod donc c'était c'est
quelqu'un de télé il se met à écrire un
second roman il avait déjà publié un
premier roman chez elle nous n'irons
plus chez elle vous connaissez bien en
87 éditions du seuil et là alors ils
règlent un peu ses comptes avec son
ancien métier de chef de produit chef de
groupe j'imagine chez l'oréal peut-être
qu'il était même monté plus haut que ça
parce que le héros eh ben il est chef de
groupe chez béa france alors bea
français un genre de danone c'est à dire
une boîte qui fait des yaourts des
bonbons dell de la bière
et puis un peu de dos aussi
peu de liquide voilà voilà un pea france
donc il est chef de groupe et pendant 22
chapitres il va se confier à sa psy et
puis petit à petit donc c'est une sorte
de monologue donc ça commence par j'ai
réussi je sais pas pourquoi je viens
vous voir et puis ça ça avance vers le
désastre à la fois professionnel et
personnel d'un schizophrène complet et
c'est la maladie à la mode c'est la
maladie du moment la schizophrénie c'est
à dire que c'est vraiment
je crois un livre sur un personnage
symbolique d'une certaine d'une certaine
société quoi où finalement la réussite
de chef de groupe chez béa france c'est
peut-être pas si terrible et il est il
est paumé il sait pas ce qu'il veut il y
accéder il a satisfait il est marié mais
frustré etc etc moi ce que j'ai bien
aimé c'est que il a un côté magna qui
fait des listes tout le temps qu'il fait
des théories surtout par exemple ils
considèrent ah oui tiens
fondamentalement les femmes n'aiment pas
la musique la preuve il n'y a pas de
grands compositeurs citez moi un grand
compositeur de musique classique gris
fer germaine germaine
deux
[Musique]
autres théories autre théorie les gens
qui restent tard au bureau n'ont pas
plus de travail que les autres mais un
problème dans leur couple ouais
ça c'est pour nous c'est pour nous on
reste trop tard au bureau
qu'est-ce qui a d'autres ah oui se
méfier des gens qui portent des chemises
blanches oui c'est tout c'est souvent
des méchants
oui je sais pas mais je sais pas très
gentil pour bhl je trouve
ya ça il ya aussi leur l'hélice du fait
des listes de tous liste de ses
fantasmes c'est un côté un peu amélie
poulain mais amélie poulain qui aurait
lui l'essentiel du management donc c'est
que lisent des conneries faites cette
année les défis que j'aimerais sauter
liste des rêves idiot que je fais en
réunion des défauts que je préfère chez
les gens liste de mes théories
voilà des arguments du matin pour
commencer un régime pour être clair
c'est très vivant c'est peut-être un peu
un fourre-tout de quelqu'un qui a pris
des notes et qui en a fait à lille mais
en même temps c'est très juste très
réaliste et on sent qu'il sait de quoi
il parle
voilà moi je pense que comme je disais
en commencement ans comme en commençant
en commençant
c'est que il ya peu de romans sur
l'entreprise en france ça c'est beaucoup
en amérique et beaucoup de livres sur
des directeurs du marketing sur sur des
pdg ou des livres comme ceux de john
grisham qui sont très documenté sur les
cabinets d'avocats et c'est en france à
part rené victor pilon l'imprécateur et
puis extension du domaine de la lutte de
houellebecq il ya eu assez peu de lille
comme ça et finalement ça une utilité
moi je trouve que en lisant des romans
on a un regard plus distancié et plus
documenté et peut-être même tient en ce
moment où on s'aperçoit que les sondages
disent n'importe quoi que la presse
n'est pas vraiment libre et puis se
trompe souvent le regard des écrivains
sur la réalité nous apprend plus et nous
informe que finalement beaucoup plus je
crois que la presse ou que la télé faire
et je pense dans mais je crois et je
crois que si on avait évolué beaucoup de
livres cette année mais en ont par
exemple moi je la montée du fn on
pouvait la sentir dans des bouquins
comme ceux d'eric reinhardt
d'aider des livres qui montrait le
désespoir total désarroi et c'est donc
les écrivains ont finalement peut être
une utilité nouvelle qui est de nous
informer voilà nous apprendre des choses
c'est déjà le cas des romans du xixème
tandis que je
c
et puis et puis voilà j'aime bien aussi
le fait que thierry bizot ce soit
quelqu'un qui est qui a du pouvoir qui
participent à ce monde et qui en même
temps crache dans la soupe ça fait du
bien c'est c'est véritablement un
exutoire un défoulement et les lignes ça
sert aussi à ça va être un peu plus
libre que d'autres endroits voilà donc
ça s'appelle ambitions et compagnie
c'est aux éditions du seuil et la
couverture est joli prix
blanche avec notre portrait de
l'écrivain israélien amos oz à
l'occasion de la traduction chez
gallimard de seule la mère en roman
empreint de mysticisme biblique dans
lequel aux des livres en filigrane un
sage message de paix pour olivia
benhamou c'est pas de l'hébreu magnéto
amos oz et sans doute l'écrivain
israélien le plus connu d'abord pour ses
romans traduits dans le monde entier
mais aussi pour ses articles très
engagés en faveur de la paix et d'un
partage d'israël en deux états
indépendants un message sous jacent à
son oeuvre romanesque et qui habite
discrètement son dernier livre celle la
mer 0 mone mais capot mais qu il ya
un horrible amis de barzé l'aurait
quinzaine au paysage the preliminary
bord et les minimoys autre ennemi
szczecin gamma meeting in a single you
see me now 6 po box groupe j
à s'est fait raser ou bête mythique
avenue aussi pour misty alive shaochun
conrad et abyane jeune homme cour
d'école du match mon
regard et michel carreau vos méthodes là
regard imad
nofan on cale nos épées end à valsonne
au monsieur michaud nevin amis l'olivade
bana et hd à marc cherry
en virtuose de la prose poétique amos oz
10 une intrigue où les personnages se
croisent se quittent leur point commun
c'est bat yam un faubourg de tel aviv
sans histoire il aime qu'on sache où tu
oses l'oma comme celle mythe narrabeen
velo cello crime l'habitacle est venu
chez le patriote hing dominant chez les
intellectuels et nous allons roman dans
les territoires et en israël
j'invite sauf à ta femme lori motard
avait zéro
en haschich écrit mme fatiha malter
rhône et l'onu et dont on estime les
divines
d'aberdeen
me sellini l'homme et céline globalement
zain zain à plymouth veillot merad
michèle assez trash a nommé la palestine
a in the bat yam
dans l'oeuvre d'amos oz les mains occupe
autant de place que les vivants et ne
les quitte jamais une conviction qui
s'exprime aussi dans ses prises de
position politiques
[Musique]
heureusement
la musique au barcelo l'amazone en
inhalant un héros de série mad men
yakult honsha rafat qui marchent à
décorer les chars ou ben arfa
guides ou des
oeuvres magistrales sur l'espoir d'une
paix à venir ce roman sonne comme la
prière d'al aïd à ses frères humains
s'est fait raser on s'est fait heurter
aux lobbys avait la mine au relais
technolac nationale zidane
v1 et crochet chez laurie mundo daté que
vous le mythe a mis en boîte
merci olivier labbé d'amour non j'ai
juste je suis en train de le lire
sanaryenne lugubre parce qu'il a l'air
un peu solennel c'est plus le travail
c'est extrêmement drôle oui la musique
de fond lui qui parle de son mouvement
pacifiste il est il a fondé le mouvement
pacifiste la paix maintenant et je
voulais rappeler ce roman de alone à
remy autres israélienne qui s'appelle
suzanne la pleureuse qui est aussi
désespérée pathétique et drôle que les
ce livre voilà et c'est une vision qui
est peut-être mystique m'enfin c'est
quand même ils seraient une ligne
ajoutons que nous voyons le très très
joli jardin et la cour intérieure de
gérer les nombreux tout à fait agréable
bien hector bonsoir bonsoir on continue
avec hector obalk le critique qui
n'amuse pas la galerie mesdames et
messieurs j'ai un peu le trac
aujourd'hui pourquoi mon bébé parce que
je fais une chronique est à la fois un
peu narcissique donc ccc ya toujours un
peu gênant puisque on va faire un petit
une rétrospective
intello parce qu'on a fait depuis un an
intello un peu théorique si vous voulez
survivre les causeries sur l'arrêt des
causeries sur la gamme un mois je dirais
qu'une hâte de trois sortes il ya celle
de l'historien d'art est un chercheur et
qui est là pour vous situer dans un
contexte historique et c'est le critique
d'art qui est plus littéraire et qui est
plutôt là pour apprécier ou faire juger
juger les heures et les faire apprécier
et puis il y aurait le nôtre catégorique
ce que les esthéticiens où l'esthétique
est là pour répondre à des questions du
genre qu'est ce que l'art du genre
pourquoi y aurait-il les oeuvres bonnes
des mauvaises du genre de quels moyens
disposent tous de quelle légitimité at
on pour juger en bien ou en mal telle ou
telle oeuvre et c'est la question que
monsieur poser à moi-même de quelle
légitimité
puis-je me réclamer pour nous en tout
cas comment quels moyens et j'utilisais
pour pour faire apprécier ceci ou cela
est le moyen le plus prosaïque le plus
simple celui qui demande pas des tonnes
d'intelligence mais qui est toujours
très efficace c'est tout simplement de
décrire ce qu'il y a alors le premier
magnéto cuche est un c est toute chose
il ya que des descriptions
magnéto c'est parti les sonars
c'est le tableau qui permet le zoom mais
plus émouvant qui soit on passe
directement de la solennité du les
volleyeuses voie politique sous un toit
d'église à quoi à quoi à l'image hyper
moderne de visages coincé derrière des
barreaux de prison regardez cette scène
où celle là pierre pense à autre chose
et c'est virginie monnier qui fait ta
juste titre marquer la silhouette de
cette tête épouse exactement celle du la
sto du bilboquet pour un tableau très
original au détail sont plus beaux les
uns que les autres aussi austère que
doux 10 images par détail 25 images par
secondes vous n'avez qu'à enregistrer
l'émission si vous trouvez que ça va
trop vite - souvent parfaitement
personnellement et le miroir ouvrages et
du fonds reflète dans un conte kabylité
l'union du couple flamand chef-d'oeuvre
attention aux trois banderilles à vaquer
y avoir quatre personnes qui vont entrer
dans un des plus jolis pavillons de
l'expo je ne manque pas il s'agit d'une
boîte magique on pourrait dire de
section triangulaire avec un bronze sur
chaque fâchent ont été massives les gens
sont deux dents au dehors tu regardes
bien un moment où paris sont 12 alors
que nous on veut 4 leur étonnement fait
un peu la gaieté du dispositif jusqu'à
ce que sonne l'heure au second de 120 et
aux lèvres meurt dans c'était donc le
best-of
dernière émission et que la dernière
comme j'ai une expo que je vois que j'ai
décalé est ce que je peux faire ce que
j'ai dit je pense que c'est amélie
poulain mais une amie poulain qui
seraient abonnés à l'essentiel du
management depuis la couverture est
jolie couverture vous l'avais dit je
viens de dire on va se tester au flanc
et burqa mais il ya beaucoup de gens
oublient de crise il faut pas décrire il
faut toujours interprété il faut donner
un sens il faut révéler la chose cachée
pour montre la montrer au soleil de
l'interprétation général c'est l'exégèse
moi je suis pas du tout dans l'exégèse
ça se limite souvent à faire ah bah
tiens vous avez pas reconnu que c'était
ça en fait c'est ça et donc deuxième
année de ces partis
plus grands bourgeois brugeois si j'ose
dire giovanni à moulle fini d'un geste
auguste présente au regardeur sa belle
épouse qui semble enceinte devant un
baldaquin dont le tissu en mayotte peut
être symboliquement l'enfant qui va
paraître et puis peut-être que le plus
original c'est celui ci qu'est ce qui
représente je recule je recule parce
qu'il faut le voir de loin c'est un lit
défait c'est un lit défait après une
nuit de sommeil par je dis bravo mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce trou qu'est
ce que c'est de se trouver bien c'est
une seat c'est une astuce ce sont les
parois d'une grotte vu de l'intérieur et
qui donne à voir un paysage sommet robes
à un paysage sommaire au bas à la
strindberg je redescends par l'ascenseur
l'ascenseur bleus luxueux silencieux
hydraulique james bondien du côté cour
qu'est ce qui lie à regarder bien jeu
jusque vous voyez je le retourne pour
vous frayer il faut découvrir un autre
profil barbu tels que strinberg se
plaisait tant voir dans les tâches
d'encre dans le frottage d'un trappe
dans les circonvolutions de vos clients
c'est aussi cela se traduirait donc
j'espère que maintenant nous avons fait
le tout il a pété
si vous
vous puisque après tout je parle pas
derrière le dernier l'avant dernier
point on en avance tout doucement on y
arrive c'est que révéler le cash est ce
ce n'est pas mon fort ce n'est pas ce
que je préfère moi j'ai pour toi
toujours montré d'évidence et quand il
s'agit de faire entrer le spectateur
dans le monde d'un artiste il s'agit
pour moi et c'est ce que je trouve le
plus efficace est de montrer que serait
la chose quel serait le le truc qu'il
serait le l'objet même anodins qui tout
d'un coup définir et l'oeuvre dans son
entier rice étaient les boîtes je me
rendis c'était l'entrecuisse ché ché
balthus c'était la roche g boecklin
allons-y c'était avant dernier magnéto
partie magnéto et comme si calme le plus
mystérieux ce sont ces briques c'est
parallélépipède de maths qui n'ont rien
à faire avec une nature morte en mal et
qu'on retrouve partout différentes
tailles en différentes couleurs et je
suis si par exemple on va le voir de
loin alors je vous fait souffrir en
restant comme ça 4,5 secondes loin mais
c'est tellement beau de loin et puis on
va comprendre en approchant que la
brique donne en fait tous on boira
essentiel un tableau qui sans elles
risqueraient l'ennui vivre la banalité
ce sont des ce sont des briques ce sont
des boîtes ça donne de la solidité
d'étrangeté au tout est la plus belle
arrive dans quelques secondes blanche
très lumineuse vous en savez assez pour
que je ne commente plus
là aussi presque dans la même position
c'est au feu de la cheminée et non plus
au ray de la lumière que s'expose
l'entrecuisse nubile j'ai tenté de mieux
étudier la position des corps chez
balthus voyez comme ça ce n'est pas
exactement du vél tus et comme ça dans
pas longtemps ça commence en être bref
une jambe droite et l'autre et l'autre
et les fléchi car c'est la texture
continuellement nourri de cette falaise
improbable qui donne de la crédibilité à
son effet à de son échelle à son
habitation à sa puissance car la roche
irrégulière voyez ça c'est tout ma thèse
est en réalité l'élément essentiel de
l'art de boecklin c'est la pierre
couverte de lichens trou et escarpé
souvenez-vous des tableaux qu'on repasse
là en ce moment en revue et qui donne
toute sa monumentalité ils sont bien
plus de présence que ce couple
d'amoureux ce sont les éléments
mystiques lumineux expressif par tous
les pores de leur paroisse qui font le
signe de buzz clean ce n'est pas fini
[Musique]
voilà c'était obalk par obalk et il n'ya
pas les conseillers de la copine qu'on a
vu un moment là les exposer ou chez lui
visite privée vous me décontenancé là
alors souvent les gens me disent et
alors c'est à dire d'accord c'est off
passionnante ça va y en a un qui adore
les briques l'autre les l'entrecuisse le
dernier les roches qu'est ce que ça peut
changer à ma vie qu'est ce que ça
changera aux choses que je vois qu est
ce que ça change au monde que j'habite
alors je ne suis pas comme bd je ne
pense pas que ça va changer le monde la
littérature va changer le monde par
contre je vous serai à peinture va aider
à le regarder autrement et c'est
évidemment en désespoir de cause mon
dernier argument on va voir autrement la
mer on va voir autrement le désordre
d'une foule on va voir autrement la rue
qu'on regarde en ouvrant la fenêtre et
je laisse à thierry ardisson de soin de
dire d'ailleurs oui mais pas trop tôt
magnéto d'abord la mer qu'est ce que
c'est bon je n'apprendrai rien à
personne en disant que ce sont des
vagues parfois gross qui plus on lève la
tête diminue de taille pour devenir
moyenne et c'est plate à l'endroit de la
ligne d'horizon qui droite par
définition par ton pardon de toutes ces
évidences or ce que va faire strinberg
c'est de ne conserver que les grosses
vagues du bas et le ciel duo en
supprimant la partie du milieu cette
vision qui est impossible impossible
quand on regarde la mer v du quai à et
la plus naturelle quand on est en bateau
les grosses vagues projets directement
leurs silhouettes sur l'horizon
[Musique]
conséquence c'est que la mer est un mur
est ce qu'il y à du vide derrière ce mur
un espace vide vertigineux presque un
trou entre la mer et le ciel qui
n'existe pas dans la réalité mais qui
renvoie exactement sentiment qu'on peut
avoir en bateau sur une mer démontée ou
quand on nage entre deux rouleaux de
même que dans l'installation de dan
graham les gens qui étaient venus pour
voir se sont trouvés faire partie d'un
tableau entre guillemets parfois fort
réussi hésitant dans un moment de grâce
entreprendre la pause ou prendre la
fuite de même le tableau de vélasquez
donne à voir ce qu aucun peintre ne
montre jamais pas seulement l'envers du
décor je veux dire mais cette réalité
non surveillées presque nous ont composé
où plus personne ne prend la pose devant
diriger il est fait en pâture ce qui est
plus difficile à rendre c'est le léger
des ordres de la vie le temps d'une
faction de voir petit repos à nouveau en
longeant les salles l'histoire de revoir
en pensée tous combien régurgiter et ça
fait quand même pas mal de touches ou
trente tableaux et je tombe
naturellement sur ce 3ème paysage carrez
également avec au mur impro premier plan
les volets me font vaguement penser à ce
qu'on aperçoit par les fenêtres de
l'expo mais ça reste encore anecdotique
avec toutefois le même genre de verdure
rampante dr le nylon que celle du
versant des arbres de tout à l'heure ce
ne sont pas les jardins d'à côté qui
ressentent au tableau complément bien
c'est nous qui commençons à voir du
morandi partout et même et même si je
rentre ma caméra par la fenêtre je
retrouve je retrouve exactement la même
division verticale le même désordre de
verdure la même sobriété et paysages du
paysage comme si mon rendez vous avait
donné ses yeux pour voir le reste de la
réalité c'est ça l'empreinte que peut
faire des grandes oeuvres sur notre
petite cervelle très brillant merci
merci de m'avoir soutenu
c'est vrai je même accueilli après votre
escapade j'ai une idée chef la semaine
prochaine je ferai mon worst of voilà je
crois pas dur après les pubs place à
notre invité du jour le comédien andré
dussollier à la fiche de monstres sacrés
sacré monstre au théâtre de la gaîté
montparnasse à plus
[Musique]
chers amis chers ennemis renou recevant
maintenant andré dussollier à la fiche
de monstres sacrés sacré monstre au
théâtre de la gaîté montparnasse bonsoir
andrée bon son arrivée un mauvais jour
le chien de philippe est dans la
cbat chahid à manger de lentilles
limaces
voilà donc pas mort il est passé deux
jours
c'est à l'école
andré frédéric beigbeder est allé voir
votre spectacle il a adoré et il va nous
expliquer de quoi il retourne alors
c'est un spectacle qui devrait être
remboursé non pas par la sécurité
sociale mais par le ministère de la
culture car andré dussollier rend la
poésie pas chiante alors évidemment ça
tous les gens qui disent des poèmes sur
scène disent la même chose je suis là
pour transmettre ce cet art sublime
sévère formidable je ne suis qu'un
truchement ce que dit souvent lui qui
n'est d'ailleurs quantico tilly il n'est
qu'un interprète vulgaire de choses qui
lisons supérieur est en fait en fait
vraiment la voix d'andré dussollier sa
façon d'être ces changements de passy
passe de textes très marrant à d
extrêmement bouleversant très triste et
le choix qu'il a fait lui même et
l'enchaînement bien construit de tout ça
fait qu'on ne sent même pas une seconde
je vous le jure j'emmène ma voilà je
vous le garantis je sais pas je fais
comme pivot je vous rembourse le biais
vraiment et donc donc voilà j'ai jeu
c'était pendant le printemps des poètes
je suis allé voir et je pensais que
enfin je ne savais pas que ça reprenait
et vraiment c'est savoir encore de la
gaîté montparnasse à 20h30 un demain
demain et il est donc quels sont les
textes que vous dites alors il y en a
pas mal ça passe ça alterne entre hugo
vini et du billard des choses graves
comme disait fabriquer puis des choses
légères comique drôle enfin
je me suis fait plaisir c'est à dire
j'ai choisi des textes qui me plaisait
j'ai dû en éliminer pas mal
et puis je voulais pas que ce soit comme
une addition de textes d'un récital en
parisis tam et quelque chose on loue le
spectateur subi comme ça une addition
mathématiques de textes sons qu'il
fallait qu'il y ait une sorte de montage
mais certains suggèrent que et voila
voila il ya détient thème quand même qui
est un peu
qui ressort majoritairement c'est sur le
sentiment amoureux alors il est
développé comme 50 il a et quand il est
vécu pleinement avec edmond rostand
horrible as you go et puis après on s'en
moque je m'en moque assez vite et là
j'ai recours guitry wii ou à la b2
l'atteignant qui
- la chose par exemple où c'est une
manière de ceux de rigoler un petit peu
de tout ça des sentiments puis du
billard aussi enfin voilà il est c'est
un privilège de pouvoir jouer un sur une
heure comme ça avec plein d'auteurs en
général on a un auteur à sa disposition
là on peut je passe d'une époque à
l'autre d'un style à l'autre c'est un
peu la diversité est aussi avec des
aphorismes pour casser le rythme et
c'est pour pas être dans pour surprendre
un petit peu ce qui est marrant c'est
que dans la salle les gens ne savent pas
forcément puisqu'il ne dit jamais le nom
de l'auteur des textes qu'il dit qu'il
réussit donc dans la salle quelques fois
ya des gens qui tournent un peu le le
programme pour essayer de cesse de suite
savoir et mon regard de simulation
cesser cette espèce importe c'est qu'il
se laisse emporter qu'il je commence
avec d'ailleurs avec un texte guitry qui
met beaucoup puisque c'est se tirer
d'une petite pièce eta qui s'appelle
caen demain soir quand on est seul et
c'est un homme qui arrive chez lui et
qui enfin est tranquille et qui se
laissent aller à dire à haute voix tous
ces sentiments donc ça me permet comme
ça de de passer d'un auteur à l'autre et
et même j'ai constaté au fur et à mesure
du spectacle c'est pas mal d'avoir des
silences entre chaque texte comme ça
comme si on suivait le fil de la pensée
de l'acteur qui est en train de vivre
quelque chose de cet homme en tout cas
qui rentrait chez lui qui est enfin seul
et qui parle à haute voix mais puisque
je vous ai sous la main je voulais juste
avoir le la tirade sur l'imparfait du
subjonctif cesser le fond services en
haut c'était de qui ça c'est la
complainte amoureuse en effet de la
conserver
puisqu'il est relative aux courses et
une pensée très très drôle délateur
nancy va tarder à le regarder si vous
le maniez tôt que je vous emm à ce
que vous me désespère acier
etc enfin je mopi n'y a trace
et que je vous dit la trace pour que
vous passez six nations
la magie la télévision vous le faites
par là c'est fort ça ça me permet ici à
spa après cet excellent à d'enchaîner
sur un du billard qui est une petite
saynète du billard a écrit des
diablogues et je me suis amusé ça
fonctionne en monologue et là il parle
d'une vieille actrice puisque justement
oui ça va bérénice nage bien l'image est
oui mais il fait tout très bien séduire
plus de tact et magnéto j'ai jamais vu
autant cessé de l'actrice qui ce guidage
le mieux
à padoue aux molières vous avez lu vous
avez dit à dublin petit du billard
sur la tragédie classique seulement et
non je sais qui est un critique dans le
grand journal vous n'êtes pas au courant
qui a fait un papier qui vous démolit
qui me dit ce nul il a même plus le voir
vous saviez pas je me suis je pour 3
juillet
authentique l'euro tandis que les types
en profite pour faire une digression sur
la médiocrité des acteurs alors c'est
qu'on attendrait donc maintenant entre
deux tournages de films vous irez faire
comme ça des petits séjours sur scène
pour nous ravir et la scène c'est
vraiment le oui c'est le lieu de
l'acteur est un peu d'autonomie c'est
une manière de reprendre loi au moule
des images justement son trafic et où il
ya beaucoup d'effets spéciaux enfin
c'est pas on passe d'un extrême à
l'autre avec la scène c'est vrai et
aussi peut-être c'est une question que
vous avez posée pourquoi il ya tant de
spectacles avec dirty fonzy anwar et
contemplation
ficoba y avait bernard
leleu dans le même registre est ce qui
se rapproche le plus de ce que vous
faites c'était geneviève page je sais
pas si vous l'aviez pas vu mes emmerdes
voiture et c'était bien aussi parce que
c'était très intime c'est très lent
voyez ça elle sait ce qui s'est vraiment
l'univers du soleil vers souvent quand
les quand ils sont seuls en scène enfin
ça arrive qu'ils fassent que l'acteur
fassent des commentaires et vous n'avez
pas eu envie ce vous êtes de purement
voilà je me sers un peu d'aphorismes
comme ça de choses moi je le sers
toujours des auteurs oui mais j'aime
j'avais envie puisque vous avez dit ça
en exergue c'est à dire où en
introduction plus tôt c'est à dire que
je voulais que ce soit vivant je conçois
pas que la poésie se soient dit sur un
certain ton un agent se gagnent à la
main canada
bon et je pense que c'est quelque chose
de vivant c'est un monologue certes mais
c'est comme j'ai toujours considéré le
monologue comme un dialogue avec des
gens qui sont là dans la salle qu'ils
sont silencieux qui pourraient
intervenir je raconte des histoires donc
racontant des histoires il ya un
suspense il ya des silences je ne
conçois pas les mots sont si denses et
il ya il y à en créer la vie quoi aussi
bien avec un poème qui avec une petite
scène de théâtre mais celle du soulier
le commentaire est dans le filet dans le
visage et dans la gestuelle et dans le
il en joue terriblement de sa visage
d'ordre est de cibler les silences les
arrière-plans j'aime beaucoup
on est dans un mas est vrai dans un
théâtre où les auteurs parlent beaucoup
font beaucoup parler leurs personnages
les personnages alors on a l'impression
d'ailleurs qui n'a plus rien à jouer
tellement dit d'un personnage dit tous
ces sentiments grâce aux mots or je
prétends quand même c'est peut-être
aussi une influence des acteurs
américains qui ont eu un langage assez
concis où il ya beaucoup je pense à pine
terre
à ces écrivains là qui permettent aux
acteurs de mettre beaucoup de choses
dans les silences et je trouve que la
jouissance du spectateur c'est de voir
un peu tout ce que ni le personnage
autant dans les mots que à entre ou
avant les mots vous après enfin voilà
donc je sais ça le plaisir de l'acteur
je trouve c'est pas seulement
l'intonation mais c'est aussi tout ce
qu'on vit quoi et on peut le faire aussi
bien avec un poème avec une
donc ça c'est je répète et la gaîté
montparnasse à 22h37 dur quoi une heure
et puis ensuite il ya cristiana reali
donc avec boris terral il
a essayé d'oublier alors racontez nous à
part ça les projets cinéma les projets
cinéma et bien un film avec jean becker
et que je vais retrouver pour la
troisième fois et toujours avec jacques
villeret aussi il y aura cette fois
thierry lhermitte et benoît jamie
magimel à partir d'un livre de michel
quint qui s'appelle croyable ah oui
bien sûr il faut être vraiment énorme
effet la voie aux
familles et puis après je retrouverai
j'espère à l'aréna qui va faire un film
avec encore
de belles idées originales on va dire je
n'en dis pas plus c'est toujours une
surprise avec lui de film en film on
n'est jamais sûr le même thème sur la
même manière de traiter des choses et on
devrait se retrouver en troupe
habituelle avec lui à l'automne voilà
qui ont ensuite
très bien merci beaucoup donc à la gaîté
montparnasse et au studio théâtre je ne
veux pas faire que du solitaire mais si
je vais jouer parce qu'il ya un théâtre
maintenant qu'il y en ait qui pour les
auteurs français que dirige jean michel
ribes les hivers trop du rond point et
en mai prochain profitant de cette année
comme ça parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
souffert aussi beaucoup c'était aussi
une des raisons pour lesquelles les
acteurs s'approprie comme ça la scène
avec des auteurs qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude ou la possibilité de jouer
ailleurs
on n'a pas pu jouer beaucoup d'auteurs
français là je vais saisir l'occasion de
ce théâtre du rond-point pour jouer des
textes paul fournel et qui s'appelle les
athlètes dans leur tête ce sera la
première fois qu'on entendra n'ont pas
la langue de bois des athlètes après
leur exploit mais là au moins il penser
ce qu il
j'éprouve après leur victoire ou leur
défaite et c'est donc ça c'est des
petits monologues et après ça je pense à
des pièces aussi que j'ai envie de jouer
je vais pas envie de m'isoler comme ça
d'un seul sur une scène mais j'aime bien
partager je pense à des pièces que j'ai
envie de jouer
quelle pêche
après les pubs placer la deuxième
invitée du jour denise bombardier
hauteur de ouf chez albin michel a plus
[Musique]
chers amis chers ennemis re re re on se
retrouve avec notre coup de zoom sur le
boom de la culture gothique à l'occasion
du festival decide à la loco le 13 mai
le pessimisme néo-romantique hérité du
pinde vampirise aujourd'hui non
seulement la musique mais le cinéma la
littérature et la peinture
renault santa maria à trouver ça
démoniaque magnéto
quel est le point commun entre la
famille addams bram stocker matrix et
les cuves au la culture but la baignoire
la culture gothique
le mouvement gothique analyse son passé
son présent et son futur comme étant
sombre et donc ça a donné naissance à
toute une mode très très noir niveau
vestimentaire au niveau musique héritier
du funk avec un côté un peu glam
décadent qui venait directement de bowie
ou ce spleen ce côté très sombre s'est
exprimé dans chez des groupes comme cube
comme déjà dit les jeunes comme
succès and the banshees donc des
héritiers du punk mais avec une
esthétique plus néo romantique
volontairement quand années dans l'ombre
l'esthétique gothique va bientôt être
mises en lumière par le biais du cinéma
dans les années 90 l'image du gothique
s'est popularisé grâce à de grands films
on connaissait bien sûr le nosferatu de
murnau ou alors les prédateurs dans les
années 80 mais là au début des années 90
il ya toute une série de films qui vont
vraiment populariser cette image donc il
ya les films de tim burton avec winona
ryder dans beetlejuice mais aussi donc
johnny depp dans edward aux mains
d'argent il ya évidemment le dracula de
coppola il y abondent de grands films
comme ce croquis qui va vraiment
font apparaître partout cette image
cette icône gothique et bien sûr le côté
plus moderne avec matrix qui vraiment
rendu très populaire à la fois cette
image là c'est la moderniser mais qui a
aussi fait connaître cette musique
l'union entre musiciens et le cinéaste
va même donner lieu à de vrais
collaboration
de très grands groupes comme nine inch
nails rammstein est à l'heure actuelle
marilyn manson n'incarne pas à eux seuls
le
le mouvement gothique mais cette
imagerie gothique
qui fait que tout à chacun peut le
découvrir cette musique dans des bo de
films par exemple nine inch nails qui a
travaillé avec oliver stone pour la bo
des films de lynch aussi le style depuis
vingt ans les gothiques sont donc
partout comme dracula serait qu'il
éternel là dans les années 2000 est un
clair et net retour aux années 80 même
dans le milieu techno du tout les grands
groupes des années 80 influence les
grands dj techno à l'heure actuelle sauf
celles se reforme il ya un retour vers
tous ces grands groupes type new order
depeche mode qui ont énormément de
succès à l'heure actuelle est évidemment
ça jours encore plus en lavedan la
faveur du mouvement gothique qui est le
plus en plus populaire
merci et bravo renault santa maria pour
son premier sujet on peut dire que c'est
réussi
la dernière boutique vous êtes habillé
en noir donc vous êtes gotti je suis
gothique voilà ça fait mal aussi
toujours habillés en noir on poursuit en
compagnie de denise bombardier hauteur
de ouf chez albin michel bonsoir bonsoir
québécoise donc sans accent
non non jamais alors quoi non merci non
mais ça l'a dit j'en ai énormément dit
bon parce que je veux que vous méritiez
pour ce que j'ai à dire la façon dont je
lui dis alors êtes-vous gothique non pas
du tout je suis baroque moi je suis un
même juge baroque alors vous voyez que
je suis un peu plus et puis en plus que
je sais tout ce qui tourne autour des
pompes funèbres ça m'intéresse pas alors
patrice pourquoi ouf pourquoi ouf parce
que alors d'abord c'est un roman on a
peu l'habitude c'est denise bombardier
s'est plutôt des essais d'habitude ou
deux il ya quelques quelques romans mais
ouais c'est plutôt que du comme
essayiste alors c'est l'histoire de
jeunes
jade que sa maman avait appelé jeanne
d'arc au début parce que
prénommé jean dénommé jeanne d'arc parce
que sa mère n'aimait pas les angry
heureux préféré rester vierge
et alors elle a laissé tomber la
particule au bout d'un moment après il a
eu à woodstock d'une aumône wittstock
elle a eu sa première aventure amoureuse
mais n'a pas joué
parce que son amant ne savait pas si le
dit d'ailleurs il y aurait si elle est
technique tories dieng ou vaginale vous
rappelle quelque chose et alors
donc
il est venu trop vite
et donc il est venu un peu vite pour
qu'elles sachent en réalité si elle
était l'une de l'autre bon et puis donc
elle va sa ville va se marier quand même
et puis elle a deux enfants et elle se
sépare
et aux faux c'est l'histoire d'une femme
de 50 ans séparée avec deux enfants à
charge contre m il vivait avec elle
et qu'est ce qu'est ce que devient une
femme de 50 ans seul est ce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle peut encore et mais est-ce
qu'elle va encore aimer comment comment
comment va se passer ses relations avec
les hommes qu'elle va rencontrer est-ce
qu'il faut que cherche le grand amour ou
pas est-ce que c'est ce qu'elle peut
dire je t'aime ce que quand on lui dit
je t'aime celui fait plaisir ou sami
frey 1 mais c'est surtout un livre drôle
c'est que
de toute façon s'il n'y a pas su s'il
était vaginale de crise et ce parce
qu'ils étaient américains après la
rencontre est un québécois francophone
et celui là il ya tout quand il y avait
tout compris davance alors là c'est là
qu'elle a connus comme comme l'élu est
la plus en squat et puis et puis ça
s'est poursuivi mais c'est vrai que
c'est au fond c'est toutes ces femmes
qui ont 50 ans dans le livre cette année
des personnages ses 30 ans ces femmes là
sont trop ce sont des femmes autonomes
sont des femmes qui qui sapent ce
qu'elle veut ce que ce qu'elles veulent
dans la vie sauf qu'avec les hommes et
savent plus trop bien ce qu'elles
veulent parce que parce que je trouve
que les hommes sont pas à la hauteur et
puis parce qu'elle s'amuse entrée à
entre elles enfin de tout bien tout
honneur évidemment mais de toutes les
façons parce que c'est vieillir on n'y
échappe pas eh bien il faut qu'il faut
en rire si tous donc elle se marre qu
est-ce qu on dev-yhu d'ailleurs à 50 ans
aujourd'hui
avait justement
c'est une protection des gens qui ne
veulent pas vieillir c'est cela qu'ils
ont qui sont pitoyables mais pour le
reste on n'a pas le choix alors donc on
prend le bateau et puis on fait avec ces
mots font c'est ça tu as raison
est-ce que derrière ce roman un peu la
bride t jones un peu vingt ans après est
ce qu'il ya pas une critique de la
révolution sexuelle du féminisme de tous
ces combats qui ont été aussi les vôtres
n'ont pas dissipé c'est pas une critique
c'est un constat par les femmes arrivées
est se retrouve tout seul et se disent
'mais qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on a
fait et puis et puis son mari s'est tiré
avec une une thérapie non une thérapeute
qui est spécialisée dans les essentiel
je n'avais pas son mari en était une
peut-être
mais mais non c'est parce que elle
constate autour d'elle que vous êtes
tous ses amis sont un peu seul et puis
en plus le problème des femmes de 50 ans
c'est qu'elles ont eu un comportement
très très moderne dans leur vie coureurs
dans leur vie sociale mais ils ont une
espèce de sentimentalité du dix neuvième
siècle sont complètement niaiseuse alors
là
elles sont complètement niaiseuse et
puis elle attendait attendait d'ailleurs
et savent pas ce qu'ils attendent mais
elles attendent et lb l'attend pas
tellement elle a des amis absolument
qu'ils veulent la mac est d'ailleurs
lama qui bat d'ailleurs
alors cette idée que les sommes
maintenant au tour de 50 ans partent
avec des filles de 20 ou 30 ans à
l'époque où le divorce était moins
pratique et ça n'arrivait pas est ce que
finalement c'est regrettable parce qu'il
vaut mieux un homme qui reste avec vous
qui subvient à vos besoins et à ceux de
vos enfants jusqu'à la fin de vos jours
et de séjour je vous exhorte à niveau là
dessus il passe de se poser question
alors moi j'ai choisi de rester les
mains de leur ai dit moi c'est pas ma
vie moi j'ai plutôt fait venir j'étais
j'ai même été
pourvoyeuse un certain moment donc c'est
vraiment pas ma vie à moi
convoyeuse de quoi celle inverse de ce
que faisaient les hommes
traditionnellement c'est à dire
payer une pension alimentaire
si on est au féminin est pourvoyeuse ça
fait pas pourvoyeur
mais ceci dit non parce qu'il n'y a rien
de pire que de vives offrir le pire
c'est l'ennui et moi je crois que s'il
ya beaucoup de femmes qui passent
maintenant les femmes partout si non pas
seulement parce que d'une carte de
résident lequel peuvent partir mais
parce qu'elle s'ennuie avec les hommes
et si vrai que arrivé à la cinquantaine
en général parce que si je regarde
autour de moi ici comme à montréal où
comme à new york c'est vrai c'est vrai
que les femmes ont l'air de s'amuser
dans l'est n'ont trouvé mieux qu'à 30
ans oui je le trouve moins dur que les
filles de 30 ans je les trouve mieux et
sont plus dégagées d'un certain nombre
de choses et puis alors que les hommes
vers la fin de la cinquantaine bâti
moïse oui oui c'est à dire qu'ils se
couchent le soir ils se lèvent le matin
le lendemain matin ils décident qu'ils
sont vieux et à partir du moment où un
homme décide qu'il est vieux dans sa
tête on sait ce qui se passe dans sa vie
c'est bien que dalle si bien que dans ce
livre il ya je crois un des personnages
qui dit ben j'ai passé ma vie à me
promener avec des pilule
anticonceptionnelle dans mon sac à main
est bien là maintenant et rencontre des
hommes qui sont enfin que qui sont en
question ben laisser les femmes qui se
promènent avec les pilules bleues donc
encore des pilules
et que pensez vous de cette tendance des
femmes de 50 ans et plus qui sont avec
les jeunes de 25 c'est vrai qu'il ya
tant dans
les fameux
chapeau et oui et j'ai fait une émission
à la radio ici il n'ya pas longtemps et
on m'a dit une dame kappeler elle a dit
qu'elle avait un nom de 40 ans de moins
qu'elle dans sa vie mais je pense
qu'elle avait au moins c'est bien ou pas
il fallait qu'elle avait pardon bon bah
si c'est le plaisir mais moi j'avais
jusqu'à 24 ans à une cesse des notes de
best vous savez j'aurais l'impression
vraiment adepte d'un c'est trop la
proximité avec son avec son propre
président moi personnellement mais enfin
les femmes qui sont avec des hommes qui
veulent manger beaucoup d'amis
effectivement autour de moi qui sont
avec des petits jeunes bon ben ça fait
plaisir aux à mes pieds en ssii chez
rythme mais elles sont attendez-vous
d'état cheryl cole s'est démocratisée
[Musique]
tout à fait est-ce que c'est accepter
jugement moral sur ceux là dessus tout à
fait quand même encore des gamins des
gars m'a pas mal mais comment vous
expliquez bien beaucoup d'ailleurs fait
qu'une femme ya quarante ans de plus que
moi
vous avez
justement alors est ce jeune homme plus
jeune mais c'était en tant que centre
avec des femmes de cinq ans c'est parce
que les filles de 30 ans sont trop durs
avec l iphone rennes
c'est ces gens pas le choix les voilà
comment vous expliquez que ces
phénomènes ne dépendent pas du tout
fondées société dans les clous vis et
dire que c'est vrai au québec mais c'est
vrai en france c'est comment ça se fait
que ce soit universel c'est ce qu'on
appelle la mondialisation
non il ya des réalisations c'est aussi
pourquoi
moi je parle du jeu des sifi toujours
c'est le sida aux tirs dans les pays où
ils étaient en demande accidental c'est
plus ou moins mais c'est vrai alors tant
qu on vous tient avait fait l'an dernier
un bouquin qui s'appelait donc lettre
ouverte aux français qui se prennent
pour le nombril du monde alors comment
vous analyser ce qui s'est passé en
france c'est derrière trois semaines
le danger le pen a déjà de chiffrage ça
déprimant pour t'ouvrir et puis en plus
je regarde le deuxième tour 19% pour
l'extrême droite et puis 19 % des gens
qui n'ont pas voté je me dis qu'il ya 38
% ya presque 40 % des français qui sont
dans une situation politique que je
trouve moins périlleuse et en plus c'est
qu'au premier tour il y avait le choix
vous avez pré botté pour les chasseurs
ils pouvaient voter pour les fumeurs de
joints il y avait vraiment le choix ils
ont qu'à l'extrême droite et ça je
trouve que c'est pas évidemment c'est
pas la france qui s'est pas la france
qui m'attire et c'est pas c'est pas la
france pour laquelle je reviens ici ça
c'est ce et au québec
n'ont que la température mais on n'a pas
de y'a pas d'extrême gauche n'y a pas
une extrême droite ça n'existe pas et
c'est surtout pas institutionnaliser il
ya bien des gens dans leur salon qui
vous disent des choses sur les juifs
sont les noirs sont des guides ça mais
il ya toujours des indépendantistes de
vieillesse au pouvoir
et gouverner au québec
m'enfin ça n'a rien à voir avec la
gauche et la droite
enfin je suis très heureuse qu'on n'est
pas là je trouve que là on était
exemplaire franchement vous me direz
vous n'avez pas été colonisateurs vous
me voyez de colonies c'est vrai on n'a
pas été impérial est ce qu'on n'a pas
peut-être pas une chance d'être
impérialiste mais il reste une chose
mich toinon mais si ça n'est de toute
façon ils pourraient venir on a dix
migrants quand même et on pense pas les
on pense pas ouvrir les frontières pour
les jeter dehors
et puis nous les marginalité je vais
vous dire on est beaucoup plus tolérants
je crois que parce que nous même on est
une sorte de marginalité en amérique du
nord et je crois que ça nous donne une
sensibilité qui fait qu'on comprend les
minoritaires et qu'on comprend les
marginalité
au niveau fédéral au canada il ya pas
non plus d'extrême droite il ya un parti
dans l'ouest du canada qui était imparti
mais ce serait ça n'a pas de commune
mesure avec avec le parti de le pen
c'est un parti ultra-conservateur ils
sont courtes avortement ils sont en
action pour le rétablissement de la
peine de mort il trouve que les migrants
on en prend trop mais enfin il ya
personne qui tient mais discours que
vous connaissez
il ya des solutions pour salut il a pas
l'audience lisons pas l'audience qu'il a
c'est à dire ils sont tous pourris
réunion des représentants a voté moi je
veux dire ils sont ils sont actuellement
parlement mais ils tiennent pas ceux des
non pas les solutions que vous proposez
voyante à vancouver avec des réactions
vos shows très dur
on cherchait peut-être
il ya des ours
grizzly d'ailleurs il a blâmé bref tous
voilà d'ailleurs votre grizzlies vous le
problème c'est qui a été candidat au
deuxième tour vous avez été surprise et
moi que nous ne voulons pas de la france
mais je vais vous dire que quand je lis
eu quand on m'a téléphoné c'était deux
heures d'après midi pour moi le premier
tour j'ai eu carrément je vous le jure
sur la tête de mon fils la chair de
poule je me suis dit c'est pas possible
mais après coup je suis oui c'est
possible parce qu'il ya une tradition je
suis une tradition chez vous votre
histoire
vous aimez vous amène à sommes enfin
c'est très lourd et c'est pas la façon
de se mettre sur la carte du monde c'est
parce que la duran duran parce que là la
france intéresse le reste du monde
depuis de la premier tour des élections
on verra pour la suite on a un peu honte
d'un coup d'un bon là bas cela dit non
mais peut-être qu'il y en a pas au
canada mais un à un au lendemain
parce qu aux états-unis elles viennent
passer des tuyaux mais les prostituées
analyse et il est impensable comme
fasciste se retrouve en balance comme
président des états unis s'est pas
institutionnaliser donc c'est pas on est
ce que cela est ce que les extrêmes sont
pas dans le parti républicain les fonds
oui c'est la droite du casque
illusion que boucher feutchine annoncé
despatie et d'hommes qui englobe
justement ce que ce qui ici pourrait
pourrait fournir des extrêmes c'est les
gens comme goldwater tout ça s'était
cogné à sa droite
qui s'appelle bounce son fils qui
viennent si ça exactement et quand ça
arrive au niveau national dans le parti
eh ben ils se font ils se font made in
modéré et temporiser part par une sorte
de cour bien ben merci beaucoup donc je
rappelle le titre votre livre denise
bombardier ouf roman chez albin michel
merci beaucoup on continue avec notre
visite de l'imprimerie nationale connu
pour ses collections d'édition rares
l'imprimerie nationale est aussi le
musée le tous les alphabets et typo de
tous types pierre gros pot est allé se
livrer à la police magnéto
créé par françois promis au xvième
siècle imprimerie nationale tour à tour
royale et impériale est aujourd'hui un
groupe industriel d'envergure européenne
elle abrite un patrimoine exceptionnel
comme ces milliers de poinçon qui
servira certaines des plus belles
impressions de l'histoire de france
massé caractère qui date de 15 140 c du
grec à ligaturer c'est les premiers
caractères qui constituent la collection
historique
[Musique]
passe par la bibliothèque pour arriver
au cabinet des poissons de l'imprimerie
nationale donc c'est le lieu où
conserver ou en entretien
l'ensemble des collections donc ses
collections comprennent cinq cent mille
pièces toutes classées monuments
historiques
alors là c'est les plus importants
caractère de la collection des plus gros
cet accord 120 et là ici on a les plus
petits qui sont un corps 4 alors ce
corps 4 cd caractère vraiment minuscule
qui font quelques dixièmes pour certains
et qui permettait de d'imprimer des
ouvrages évidemment de petit format on
pouvait avoir des écrits l'essence yeux
on pouvait avoir des choses plus ou
moins interdite et on partait ça sous le
manteau
[Applaudissements]
et
ouais
une partie de cette collection orientale
c'est la collection de caractère et de
poinçon de hiéroglyphes qui se
répartissent en quatre grandes parties
les parties du corps humain où on voit
des petits personnages tourner à droite
ou à gauche puisque on peut écrire ou
lire dans un sens on est loin du gauche
à droite ou de droite à gauche et on a
fait partie des architectures et la
faune et la flore
[Musique]
ce patrimoine est encore vivant grâce à
des savoir-faire précieusement entre
touche en 1,75 alphabet des tibétains le
maya le chat siamois le carrosserie ont
tous les caractères arabes
même ceux qui ne compense toutefois deux
voyelles
goofy foot karabatic ou d'autres langues
ils sont
encore plus anciennes comme les et
uniformes et muni vite disons que je
savais c'est un caractère uniforme nos
garrigues 6 kg par contre faire des
achats de moderne c'est le phénicien
mais la modernité la rentabilité sont
bien là les précieux ouvrages de
bibliophilie vendus parfois plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de francs et la
collection de la salamandre plus
abordable suffiront ils à sauver ces
techniques qui confine tallard bientôt
le fondeur de l'imprimerie nationale
partir à la retraite rue de la
convention personne n'est là pour le
remplacer
merci pierre gros pot après les pubs
place à l'instant critique aujourd'hui
consacré au cinéma avec notre
cinéphilique trio elisabeth quin michel
boujut alain riou a plus
[Musique]
chers amis chers ennemis 3 foireux on se
retrouve pour l'instant critique
aujourd'hui consacré au cinéma avec
notre fameux cinéphilique trio et zabeth
cas de paris première et de l michel
boujut de charlie hebdo et alain riou du
nouvel obs celle des enfants salut
l'échiné du diable on commence
réalisation guillermo del toro avec
eduardo noriega marisa paredes et
federico lupi magnéto
[Musique]
les connaissons tout en
mêlant
[Musique]
oui
alors
si
c'était vrai auteur mary cohr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais chine du diable donc de guillermo
del toro produit par les frères
almodovar d'où ce mari comme
ça n'a rien à voir avec un film sur la
movida ou quelque chose qui
ressemblerait aux productions de pedro
almodovar je dois dire que bien que
l'ayant vu il ya quinze jours j'attends
toujours le moment où le petit garçon
que l'on vient de voir reviendrai que sa
cruche d'eau car cet enfant ma foi mais
après 40 minutes pour aller chercher une
cruche d'eau une nuit dans un dortoir
pendant la guerre civile espagnole c'est
un peu cause aides et ne revient jamais
avec sa cruche et j'ai un peu envie de
dire tant va la cruche à l'eau qu'à la
fin elle se casse c'est moi qui me suis
cassé vers la fin j'ai d'abord
cru d'accord non c'est un fils et une
série b il me semble sur les terreurs
enfantines vécue par un petit orphelin
cet enfant qu'on vient de voir pendant
la guerre civile qui est abandonnée dans
un orphelinat en pleine campagne et
l'enfant pour avoir un revenant un
spectre un fantôme un autre enfant tué
alors il ya beaucoup d'emprunts ils sont
peut-être un peu trop on a l'impression
d'être dans un bus duel au début il ya
une femme qui boite on pense à tristane
à ces marisa paredes année patrice tana
de bunuel on pense amenabar avec des
revenants ça n'est pas le talent
d'amenabar et la façon de faire peur et
de jouer du suspense bref tu ne sers
ebay aimable qui sort une semaine avant
cannes ceci explique cela et oui les
malheureux et oui sorte une semaine
avant cannes il faut le dire à notre
public chéri ben c'est pas forcément les
alors plus belle cela dit elisabeth est
peut-être un petit peu condescendante
avec ce film qui a quand même elle est
très méchante non elle est un légèrement
condescendant parce que c'est quand même
des qualités
effectivement on pense de temps en temps
à busnes de la fin de tous est ce cinéma
onirique ce cinéma un petit peu en état
de poésie l'époque n'est pas
inintéressante que ce que cet orphelinat
loin de tout ça se passe pendant la
guerre civile avec la mort qui qui qui
qui rôdent même chez les ces enfants ne
sont pas au contact direct de la guerre
mise en subissent quand même les effets
il ya quelque chose qui n'est pas
inintéressant et qui me fait penser à un
autre film espagnol qui était bien
supérieur qui s'appelle l'esprit de la
ruche qui se passait aussi pendant la
guerre d'espagne
espagnole avec une petite fille dans un
village qui allait voir franck landou ce
parce qu'elle n'avait pas le droit
frankenstein le premier du nom il me
l'immortel film de james whale et qui
devenait hanté par ce personnage le
fantasme la réalité c'est pas
inintéressant c'est court non c'est pas
franchement je ne commente pas non mais
et alors il est très doué sert au
secteur mon fils est parti avant la fin
tu n'as pas du tout non c'est con je
vais te l'histoire non mais il
l'histoire liste ou franchement histoire
- intérêt cet enfant est poursuivi par
l'inquisition
fürtwangler de istvan szabo avec avec
aït el stellan skarsgard et magnéto
watch il en est un mois nuire
au staff
itinéris six occasions
note
1 du cnrs
bernard
king
leurs baux avec harvey keitel
et c'est michel boujut qui s'y colle en
avance il a fait des progrès reach c'est
terrible c'est que l'extrait est bien
choisi oui le major arnold un l'armée
américaine est chargé
après la guerre 2d nazifié l'allemagne
et lui les charges et quand même du très
gros gibier puisqu'en fait le cas dont
il va s'occuper à voir ce à s'occuper
c'est celui de wilhelm fürtwangler
l'immense chef d'orchestre dont on nous
dit que il n'y avait pas mieux à part
toscanini ce qui est sûrement vrai
d'ailleurs j'ai écouté moi même quelques
noms bon c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
donc c'est le face à face entre ce
majeur de l'armée américaine joué par
harvey keitel et ce grand wilhelm
fürtwangler
comme dans un film de claude miller ou
ignorés lino ventura d'un côté et michel
serrault sauf que là c'est un grand
sujet l'art et la politique l'art au
service de la politique point
d'interrogation
le problème le problème majeur de ce
film d'ivan sa bosse et que harvey
keitel qui est un immense acteur que
j'adore depuis toujours chez scorsese et
les autres là je ne crois pas beaucoup à
son personnage ce majeur américain donc
qui a qui a une mission importante 1
face à ce cet homme qui essaie peut-être
peut-être compromis avec le régime du
troisième reich
il est un peu trop on dirait un petit
bouledogue dans le film qui aboie devant
le grand musicien devant le grand chef
d'orchestre qui on devient d'ailleurs
plus grand d'une certaine façon il a un
côté rageur il a un côté pas sympathique
même sa secrétaire l'assaut majeur
américain qui est une allemande qui a eu
à souffrir du nazisme lui dit la façon
dont vous interrogeait wilane sur
d'anglais me fait penser aux 1,11 à la
gestapo quand elle m'a interrogé moi
donc il a des cannes des méthodes un
petit peu brutale c'est magique c'est un
peu dommage peut-être que ça existait ce
genre de fichier faut comprendre le
contexte faut comprendre aussi
l'indignation devant l'horreur tout ça
ça frustre un peu parce que c'est un
très beau sujet j'aurais aimé que ce
soit d'homme à homme nous auriez préféré
2 dimanche les douanes égal alors que là
on a l'impression qu'elle flotte
anglaise qui a quand même pas fait que
des choses très très noble parce que
c'est vrai qu'il a dirigé le
philharmonic orchestra de berlin 2 pour
l'anniversaire du führer adolf bon et
puis leur ya une chose qui me fait un
peu sourire vous allez voir pourquoi
c'était aussi on lui reproche d'avoir
envoyé sur le front russe un critique
musical qui avait dit du mal d'un de ses
concerts alors moi ça me fait beaucoup
rire parce que je me dis peut-être c'est
ce kit si c'est ce qui nous menace tous
un jour ou l'autre on nous enverra sur
le front russe si on dit les choses
méchantes bon c'est un beau sujet et
c'est un film inaboutie pour moi
en partie mais pas celui
c'est à dire que les dégâts mais
simplement ce qu'on constate c'est que
les américains sont moins arrogant tout
le monde sait pas on est vrai nom en
tant que spectateur non en tant que
spectateur pour que le débat qui est
important entre l'art et la politique au
fond d'une certaine façon leur et
l'extermination soit plus développée et
soient plus à jeu égal voilà il y en a
un qui jappe un peu le l'américain face
à cette année également si michel sait
peut-être que dans un film comme ça
historique aussi sérieux le la
personnalité d'harvey keitel vampiris
complètement le personnage d'acteurs
inconnus tout simplement peut-être
nature inconnue vie est moins ce côté
air est un acteur inconnu - ses options
dans l'étrangleur ça n'est pas connue de
nous il est très bon sur suédois oui il
est il est très bien mais le problème
essentiel c'est que cheikh m'bengue les
recettes ce n'est pas n'importe quel
artiste c'est un poète c'est à dire
c'est à planes of legends qui l'aurions
dû diriger mozart ou certaines jeu le
prélude de parsifal savent qui plane
totalement et que c'est un homme au delà
des réalités donc l'idée c'est est ce
que l'art est ce qu un talent génial
vous donne le droit d'ignorer des
horreurs si les pam et les huit
directement les horreurs alors il aurait
fallu effectivement comme tu le dis que
le type qui est en face l'interrogateur
soit à peu près heures à l'avancé elle
représente nouy représente le pays non
il représente lui c'est à dire quelqu'un
je pense que le fond est un petit
français pas reconnu en lui voilà si
vous êtes d'accord alors oui oui oui
on ne va pas finir sur le front russe
mais si j'ai bien compris vous promener
dans le premier d'une série b finder
ou est ce que ce débat quand même idiot
au fond qu'est ce qui nous fait faire
donc là il nous refait le coup de leni
riefenstahl 10 ans et moi je fais pas de
politique je faisais de la sof vénéré
fait parler beaucoup plus louiez et que
c'était une dure pas ton disque du reich
tu as raison d'ailleurs très bien on
continue avec de majestic de frank
darabont avec jim carrey et martin
landau magnéto
non
voilà de majestic de frank darabont avec
jim carrey et martin landau et c'est le
roi du pitch qui pitch alors c'est un
film à tiroirs au début du film un
malheureux scénaristes se bat pour
essayer d'imposer un scénario devant des
producteurs imbéciles et des assesseurs
lèche pompe du producteur évidemment
ensuite nono porte par un travelling
formidable on entre en 1951 dans
l'hollywood et là on voit la chasse aux
sorcières qui décime les le mccarthysme
qui décime les jours donc le scénar al
sujet hui est impliqué alors qu'il n'y
comprend absolument rien fui dans sa
voiture tombe sur un bon c'est les
scènes magnifiques tombent dans la mer
est absolument pousser vers le rivage
père consciences se réveillent dans un
petit village merveilleux c'est jim
carrey et là il a perdu toute mémoire et
on le prend pour un héros de la guerre
qui revient et c'est le souhait du
patron du cinéma local qui a fermé
boutique depuis que son fils est mort on
le propre aéro à l'est derrière lui le
père de ce jeune homme mort à la guerre
oui
c'est pas mal on recommence ne le paient
peu importe que le faire de ce jeune
homme mort à la guerre écoutait ce que
je dis s'il vous plaît mais je veux dire
simplement que ce le héros le scénariste
donc tombent dans la mer père
consciences se réveillent ayant perdu
toute mémoire dans un village on le
prend pour un fils revenu du front que
l'on croyait mort qui se paraient c'est
le fils du patron du cinéma de village
est joué pour faire leur finaland donc
le majestic est un hommage au cinéma
tout de soutien sous toutes ses formes
c'est à dire est ce lui n'est ce pas lui
est ce que le maccarthysme va le
rattraper il ya un sujet formidable qui
rend l'aja tout cet instinct fine de
scénaristes comme le nom l'indiqué fin
comme le héros l'indiquent
malheureusement les scénarii c'est un
instrument qui n'utilisent pas
suffisamment services et la gomme et les
six ont un arrêt de deux heures trente
de ce film qui pour être génial si vous
coupez vous même mentalement dans votre
tête l'heure de trop c'est à dire les
inaugurations le chrysanthème c'est à
dire les chansons qui dure jusqu'au bout
c'est à dire le temps perdu vous avez
imaginez vous un petit bijou d'une heure
troll de mais prenez la gang
c'est bien c'est bien vu
non mais pas seulement même son point de
vue même sans point de vue un certain
intérêt non mais c'est tout à fait ça ce
film il est effectué effectivement trop
long avec des scènes un peu languissante
et ça c'est tout à fait tout à fait
fâcheux alors évidemment par rapport à
ce film on veut dire il ya ceux qui
aiment jim carrey et ceux qui ne peuvent
pas l'encaisser moi je fais partie de
ceux qu'ils l'aiment beaucoup et pas
seulement depuis truman show c'est un
acteur à transformation mais je laime
autant que j'ai aimé à l'époque jerry
lewis a oui il ya une parenté d'ailleurs
dans le transformisme comme ça et puis
c'est quand même un très beau sujet le
mccarthysme traité de façon légère
traité à la comédie traité en fait je
vais vous dire traité à la capra plus
parce que cette petite ville de
l'automne bon où il se réveille
amnésique
c'est une petite ville à la capra où
tout est possible c'est l'envers du
décor c'est l'envers du miroir et puis
il ya quand même des notions c'est de ce
garçon qui va être convoqué devant la
fameuse commission des activités
antiaméricaines de des inquisiteurs de
mccarthy au fonds bain lui qui est sans
conviction et sans courage il le dit lui
même il va il va très très bien se
comporter mieux que certains signes à ce
qu'on connaît bon il ya quelque chose et
ça aussi cette espèce de 2,2 de voile du
libéralisme américain pas au sens
économique au sens nous sommes libéraux
nous sommes pour la constitution de nous
sommes profondément des démocrates ça
passe dans le film à travers ce
personnage un peu sentimental peut-être
sur les bords je n'ai pas vu je voulais
juste vous mettre l'eau à la bouche avec
un film coréen qui s'appelle memento my
qu'être une histoire absolument
captivante de deux jeunes sud lycéenne
qui tombe folle amoureuse et une
histoire qui va se terminer de façon
tragique donc je recommande d'autant
qu'on va peut vous parler de cinéma
asiatique contrairement aux années
précédentes principal de cannes la
semaine prochaine cela mon gars il ya
peu timide et alors alors il ya un film
d'hypothéquer le le papa spirituel du
cinéma coréen est quand même vous mettre
l'eau à la bouche avec le film
d'ouverture qui est le film de woody
allen dont il sort le cas la raison qui
est une merveille alors la terrine de
scénariste je vous fais juste le pitch
vous allez voir la folie
pathologie qui est même dans
l'autodérision de woody allen c'est
l'histoire d'un zéro pointé qui avons eu
deux oscars dans une autre vie qui est
cinéaste eût fait de la pub au canada et
un kleenex femme un jour vient dire je
me suis remarié qu'un producteur tu le
sais je te propose de réaliser ce film
il accepte et qu'est ce qui lui arrive
il tombe aveugle il devient aveugle
pendant le tournage du film et l'idée
est le but du film et le propos du film
c'est de finir le film bien qu'il soit
aveugle sans que personne ne s'en rende
compte et c'est l'ouverture du festival
se détériore ddv tout va bien composer
la deuxième en état et alors il ya une
pirouette époustouflante à la fin du
film qui est un clin d'oeil d'une malice
est d'une ironie et d'une moquerie et
quitte à une déclaration d'amour de
woody allen au cinéma français et d'une
vache rit incommensurable aux
spectateurs français parce qu'il se fout
de nous avec une tendresse incroyable et
c'est une façon géniale pour lui d'avoir
gagné son ticket d'ouverture festival de
cannes fait un film sur le cinéma sur un
cinéaste aveugle il nous dit je vous
aime je vous dis pas pourquoi ni comment
y voilà et puis comme ça ça nous met
l'eau à la bouche à la à beaubourg au
centre pompidou est exactement où est un
grand cycle autour de ce merveilleux
personnage
fantômas fond ce match à travers la mer
n'est pas sûr fantômas est finie en
fantôme en soit la photo mais rien à
dire merci r d hergé s'est finie
justement pour aujourd'hui chers amis
chers et demi au revoir demain best of
de la semaine peinard à lundi 18 50 pour
un nouveau jt de la culture invités
benno besson le roi servent d'un grand
et bernard campan bon week-end comme
tous
les corrections de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu